lui poser une question alors c'est quoi
la soumission à l'autorité a été
démontré par milgram
il suffit qu'il y ait un type en blouse
blanche avec un uniforme tu insultes
mais fait des envois des madame c'est
parce que c'est la soumission natori tv
dans le monde entier oui bien que ford
et n'a pas donné ses transposer alors
eric naulleau ses missions et ont été
envoyés sur place
ouais la seule chose comme karim comme
gaspard je comprends le trouble par
rapport aux décisions contradictoires ça
c'est vrai il est passé de ça sert à
rien pour le porter en forêt alors qu'on
croise que des sangliers qui comprend
comprendre cet automne à partir de là il
ya deux phénomènes qui se développe bien
phénomène qui n'a aucune importance et
vous arrivez vous n'avez aucune
importance que vous êtes un des dix
mille visages des complotisme et du
populisme
vous avez votre quart d'heure de gloire
ensuite un mois sera une autre théorie
du complot avec quelqu'un que votre
talent puisque vous avez du bagout sa
victoire oui oui vous êtes examen si
vous allez faire une carrière de premier
vous avez pensé pouvoir étrenner
simplement il en est à quatre vingt dix
minutes chez moi mais vous pouvez
continuer à faire les marionnettes
séparé des liens vous n'allez pas
m'entraîner adam boulot
c'est parce qu'une de l'émission non
mais moi je vous écoute et très
patiemment madame j'ai écouté très
patiemment cib et commencé par entraîner
là dedans oui vous aiderez depuis
inquiétez pas sauvé jo derrière j'ai
fini alors laissez le finir votre quart
d'heure de gloire vous en êtes à 14
minutes dans une minute vous allez
disparaître dans l'obscurité et
quelqu'un va prendre votre place
moi je sais pas j'aime par semaine vous
avez un compte et je suis là je suis pas
payé 1 donc vous m et vous vous êtes
payés alors ne montrons pas du doigt
déjà baissé le doigt tarek fatah est
d'accord et ce contre quoi je sais pas
donc vous n'avez aucun d'importants
revanche c est un phénomène beaucoup
plus intéressant c'est le dr bien ce que
deux docteurs d'élise fait partie de
cette minorité médical qui se dit ah
c'est quand même plus facile d'attraper
la lumière si je suis contre c'est à
dire vous mettez les sites et les trois
auraient permis je vous ai laissé parler
tout votre souplesse les aliments ne
trouvant la mer vous pouvez si les dinos
mais nous on peut citer les plaies sans
jamais dire le contraire mais non
excusez-moi je crois ce sens eric un
homme je vous parle pas eric et éric et
stéphanie hans calme je suis très le
docteur le docteur pdc chaque conviction
je pense pas sincèrement qu'il fasse ça
pour être dans la lumière sont pas
présents j'ai fini ma carrière c'est une
deuxième carrière et je voulais pas
venir ici c'est bien merci
[Rires]
et ça moi je suis venu parce que c'est
tout j'ai presque terminé
parce que raquel garrido mais non
détonnés alors cyril est presque
terminée dix mille et nous on
on encore minuit sauf que le prétexte
changera ses portes
je portais cours je ne suis ni islamiste
ni complexe ici on a l'habitude je suis
blindé
mais là je suis vacciné pas tous en même
temps vous expliquer qu'il ya plus de
malades y a plus d'entrées en réalité
elles sont ponctuels donné très peu
basse et en tendant la main au cm2
comprendrait sa hauteur votre discours
hypo être audible si vous étiez pas
aussi excessif
y'a plus personne n'a rien vu il s'est
dit qu'il y en a moins dites le masque
on la retrouve obligé par un jeu dit du
petit pont sur la raison là dessus
moi je vais je vous pose une question il
se marre du mal à patrick patrick bédié
qui est là alors oui c'est le seul avec
stéphanie vraiment à défendre les
antilles malawi mais ce sont pas les
seuls dans la société 1001 et je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure
il ya beaucoup de médecins aussi qu'ils
sont d'accord avec patrice bellier la
courbe des hospitalisations et des décès
c'est vrai qu elles baissent
sensiblement au parc au kick julien
quand il vous dit ça une réponse claire
et nette il a il a un peu raison
statistiquement quand on regarde la cour
non mais quand on regarde la cour y à
l'instant t on peut se poser la question
soit dit en passant est sale a déjà été
dit on a de multiples contamination qui
se sont faites plus tôt chez un public
jeune fauqué fait que ces serments donc
effectivement qui fort heureusement et
moins gravement touchés par un virus
donc il va moins en hospitalisation en
réanimation au sénat quand même on a
quand même on a quand même une courbe
qui atteindrait augmenté sur la
réanimation mais je ne m'en féliciter
ces énormes enjeux énormes alors est ce
qu'il ya des personnes plus âgées plus à
risque qui sont que question contaminer
tout à fait mais donc c'est là le risque
c'est qu'on a cerises de regrets
augmentation simplement un autre message
que je voudrais pas c'est parce que je
pense c'est très important
il va y avoir parce que là je lance un
autre débat l'avait reçue de la
vaccination la vaccination contre la
grippe parce qu'on risque d'avoir le
télescopage de deux épidémies celle des
gros navires us et celle de la gripperie
avec une difficulté à faire un
diagnostic et en plus des hôpitaux qui
risque d'être surchargé moi honnêtement
on l'a déjà dit tout à l'heure si on
respecte à tout petit peu les soignants
je pense quand même qu'il faut qu'on
réfléchisse
qu'on dit sur les masques